hello everyone my name is connor and i'm
delighted to welcome you for madawi
al-rashid and jeremy bone on reform and
repression in saudi arabia now we'll be
getting underway in just a moment before
we do i'm going to run you through the
functionality of today's site for anyone
joining us for the first time or anyone
who needs a quick refresher now there's
two main ways you can get involved in
tonight's event the first is of course
by asking a question to ask your
questions simply click the q a top type
in what you want to say and hit send now
remember if you want your name to be
read out in the in the event and
subsequently in the podcast do include
your name with the question before you
hit the send button the other main way
to get involved is of course on social
media if you'd like to tweet along with
tonight's event please use the hashtag
iq2 we're also on instagram our handle
is at intelligentsquared the other thing
to note is of course before i hand you
over to our speakers is the book if you
do enjoy tonight's event and you'd like
to dig a bit deeper into mcdowell
excellent book the sun king reform and
repression in saudi arabia please do
click the link in the chat top it should
be coming up now you can go through to
primrose hill who is the intelligence
square bookseller get this very special
discount to read through the book
yourself or even get your christmas
presents in early i'm sure make a
fantastic read
now it's time for me to hand you over to
our chair for this evening's event he is
the middle east editor of the bbc he'll
be well known to many of you former lee
of the armand in the middle of east on
radio 4 as well as a correspondent in
jerusalem and prior to becoming middle
east editor please give a warm virtual
welcome to jeremy bone
thank you very much uh it's great to be
here i've really been looking forward to
this session because there's actually
there's a a lot to talk about
and we have the best person possible
to talk about
saudi arabia
madawi al-rasheed she is one of the
foremost authorities on the country
visiting professor professor of social
anthropology at the lse middle east
center she's written a number of
excellent books about saudi arabia
one about the legacy of king salman of
course the current king but now we have
this one here it is i'll wave it again
in case you didn't catch it when conor
waved it
uh the sudden king reform and repression
in saudi arabia published by hearst
as you can see from my notes in it my
post-it note sim i have read this very
thoroughly and
learnt a lot enjoyed it
and um
and you know for a foreign journalist
like myself saudi arabia to be honest
with you has always been a bit of a hard
nut to crack first of all it's quite
hard to work there
um second of all a lot of what passes
for
seemingly well informed comment i've
learned over the years is quite often
based on a bit of gossip and speculation
now um one person who wrote with a great
deal of authority of course was the late
jamal khashoggi now his appalling murder
broke the spell that had been painfully
woven
painstakingly woven i should say around
prince
mohammed bin salman the crown prince of
saudi arabia known for short of course
as
mbs
we're going to get on i'm sure to that
notorious killing and the effect of it
but
let's um madawi uh first of all let's
start with
begin at the beginning i mean did people
see him coming
thank you jeremy and thank you
intelligence square for this session um
um it wasn't um inevitable that muhammad
will rise to become the crown prince in
such a
short time given his age and his lack of
experience but i think to understand why
he came to power we have to look at the
arab uprising in
2011
when
quite a lot of dictators
looked as if they're on their way out
and saudi arabia did have some kind of
agitations uh demonstrations and the
tide was inevitably going to reach saudi
arabia because the demands of the
demonstrators in cairo in bahrain in
north africa and yemen
were exactly the same
in saudi arabia
but i think at that moment a decision
was taken
and to promote a young prince who would
uh start
social liberalization open up saudi
arabia
socially and economically but keeping
the political system intact as it is as
an absolute monarchy so the choice was
so obvious at the time that king salman
when he became king in 2015
he started promoting his one of his
youngest sons
and he was seen as the new face of saudi
arabia a so-called modern
creative entrepreneurial
and
connected to the rest of the world
through
pop culture entertainment and also
global capital and investment so
mohammed bin salman was promoted
in order to mitigate against the tide of
the arab uprisings reaching saudi arabia
is one of the features is it not in the
in the the entire region is that there's
a very young population a young
population that suffers from a lot of
unemployment
so the the the the idea then was to
connect with these people is that
correct
yes absolutely but age is a construct
really um and that's what i keep saying
yeah it is absolute construct and we
give it meaning
so
i remember western journalists talking
about the aging saudi monarchs one dying
followed and succeeded by another one
equally old and on the on the way out
and uh so
the the when
the prediction was actually rife that we
will have a young western educated
prince to become the future king of
saudi arabia but of course that didn't
happen in both situations we do have a
young prince but he wasn't western
educated and so people assume that there
is value to being young or valued to
being western educated and therefore
without understanding the the politics
of the saudi royal family it is
impossible to understand why mohammed
bin salman known as mbs became so
important and amassed so much powers in
such a short time well the politics of
that family are rather complicated and
they have been
the dom well among the dominant forces
since the 18th century of course in in
saudi arabia and the dominant force
since well for
most of the last hundred years i suppose
um
just
trying could you give us for those
of us um i would include myself in that
of course you sometimes get a bit
confused by the tangled family trees
and uh the web of power the varying and
ebbing and flowing web of power in saudi
arabia could you sum up for us what it
is we really need to know
about saudi politics that produced this
you know remarkable man
yes well there are two phases to
understand the royal family or royal
politics after the founder of the
kingdom
king abdel aziz ibn saud died in 1952
he
wanted the succession to stay within his
own sons which means that if a king dies
it is his son who be his brother sorry
who becomes king and this is unlike what
europe had experienced in its
various uh
monarchies so the succession went from
one son
of the founder to his brother
horizontally a horizontal succession
and he had quite a lot of songs i mean
estimated to be around 45 but we get to
the 1990s
and after that
the royal family was running out of
eligible young
brothers
of the king
and king abdullah saw the death of two
uh members of the royal family very
senior one his crown prince and minister
of defense who was the deputy crown
prince king
and at that point it became clear that
when salman becomes king there won't be
any brothers to succeed him or eligible
brothers they were old existing ones
or sidelined so it was time
to think about how the succession could
move from the horizontal line to the
vertical line so king salman sacked his
um mohammed binayev who was the minister
of interior and the crown prince
and promoted his own son as crown prince
but he is yet to appoint a deputy crown
prince which is their tradition in saudi
arabia and possibly because muhammad bin
salman is young
the king doesn't feel uh
that
there will be a power vacuum should
something happens to him and he is
probably unlikely to to to die and you
know as as the previous crown princes
did
now
he has been making
right from the outset
a lot of waves he really hit the ground
running
showing you know tremendous energy there
was the war not necessarily constructive
energy there was the war in yemen
that's certainly when i first became
aware of this this man and his name when
all that started
um
and then everything that's happened ever
since of course and there was that
november 2017 the extraordinary affair
in the ritz carlton uh in riyadh where
he he walled up a couple of hundred
prominent officials and members of the
the royal family and uh essentially they
had to buy their way out of that
what was the real story behind that what
is the
um
what was his motivation was he making a
point was he trying to show who's boss
or was it about
knocking corruption and trying to recoup
money that some of the notoriously
corrupt people in that country had uh
stolen
well it's absolutely not about
corruption
the problem that muhammad bin salman
because of his young age and because of
excluding
not only his own elder brother but his
other cousins who are more eligible and
who had experience in government like
muhammad binayev
he wanted to prove himself and prove
that he is tough so
he became minister of defense crown
prince head of the economic council
and
given the old age of his father he was
actually running the show but this
doesn't mean that he had the consensus
of the saudi royal family behind him
and before king salman the state was run
like a multiple fiefdoms and each senior
prince has his own ministry so prince
naive the crown prince had the ministry
of interior prince sultan had the
ministry of defense and these are the
main ministries and they were almost
like autonomous but they came together
and they did not
challenge their brother however when
mohammed bin salman was promoted in 2017
there was no consensus
of the royal family and a lot of members
of that family thought that
why mohammed bin salman when there are
eligible
princes who had more experience than him
so he is living in fear
for his life and he is worried about
coups by members of the royal family
and as such he managed to uh
to have almost all the king the sons of
king abdullah
mithrib and the others and
in the ritz carlton confiscated their
assets
because he was worried about him his
his future
in a family that has not given him the
full support and the consensus so by
promoting muhammad bin salman the king
king salman has sidelined so many other
princes
and corruption is a good cause and so
we see i mean the reason why i argue in
the book that it is this is not about
corruption it's because it was selective
and it was selective in the sense that
he cherry-picked some princes who might
pose a threat and put them in in the
ritz carlton and the the detention
campaign against members of his own
family continued i mean the last uh we
heard about such a
detection was just like uh seven eight
months ago and he will continue to do
this
in the future simply because um he
doesn't have that consensus that is so
important to to have the family behind
you and at the moment they're all gone
silent
for the moment do you think that might
last there is uh it's not unknown for
saudi king to be removed from power in
the past uh do you think that
um he might
uh one day just simply run out of his
nine lives well historically there has
been cases of saudi kings removed from
power the last one i don't want to go
into the 19th century and what happened
then but in in the 1960s uh king saud
was deposed forced to leave the country
and he died abroad and
because
faisal his grandparents
challenged him and kicked him out
and then in 1975 king faisal himself was
assassinated by his nephew in the palace
so it is not unlikely or unimaginable
that we'll have this kind of situation
especially after king salman dies as
king salman at the moment gives him a
legitimacy umbrella he's like the
untouchable now because he's the the
bright or so-called reformer of the sun
king but after salman dies who knows
there was an interesting story in the
guardian the other day about the former
crown prince
mohammed bin nayef who's been well no
one's quite sure but he appears to be
under house arrest and has been for
months on end and for those who didn't
see the story it was essentially saying
that there was a plot on social media
accusing him his lawyers said this
accusing him of uh plotting a coup
perhaps an alliance with joe biden and
don't forget of course that nbs is a is
being a big friend of of president trump
and also the first son-in-law jared
kushner
and uh so the quote was that interested
me was it said that this the social
media activity was coming from inside
saudi arabia and quote 40 of the tweets
apparently show bot-like behavior now
mbs himself
and his allies have quite adeptly used
social media haven't they to push their
their points do you think that is a
continuation of it of that of that
tendency yes when um mohammad bin nayef
was
detained almost like 10 months ago and
there were uh rumors on twitter also by
bots and you know uh
the
infamous twitter farm outside riyadh and
that he was on drugs and then now they
think that uh with the change in the
american administration maybe muhammad
bin naif will be revived and brought
back simply because mohammed bin laden
was the choice of many western
government including britain because of
his work as uh in the war on terror and
he cooperated and provided information
shared uh information on terrorism with
western intelligence services so it in
actually before he was deposed only a
week before he was deposed he was given
one of the most prestigious cia
medals for his uh contribution to the
war on terror but then suddenly mohammed
bin salman
became the face of saudi arabia and
muhammad bin nayef sunk into oblivion so
i'm not surprised that these tweets are
are circulating at the moment but
muhammad binay for muhammad bin salman i
mean they both have a record of
repression mohammed bin naif was
so
hated by many people in saudi arabia
because he actually
started the in the police state and
consolidated the surveillance and the
technology that makes every saudi
citizen very very vulnerable
and
it is ironic that the the work that
muhammad binayev had done has benefited
his successor which is mohammed bin
salman
and he wasn't able to to actually
benefit from all that spying and
surveillance that he he put in place
we can't talk about saudi arabia without
talking about religion and we can't talk
about religion in saudi arabia without
talking about the very longs there is a
dog who's just trying to climb up on
here but thank you pardon he's trying to
lick me um we cannot talk about uh
religion in saudi arabia without talking
about the
wahhabi version of islam and the
alliance between the al saud family and
that particular
tendency in religion that goes back
until the middle of the 18th century
is there a sense now though that that
mohammed bin salman is
is trying to do things a bit differently
that he is not
trying to be as reliant on that alliance
with the wahhabi rubber stamp as his
predecessors might have been
yes but as you mentioned the wahhabi
tradition was instrumental in in the
foundation of the state
but mohammed bin salman wants to reverse
that
he is yet to succeed simply because he
still needs the wahhabis so to just give
you examples and
he told the guardian
to mention his interview when he said
that he wants to start a moderate islam
in saudi arabia and moderate islam
involves sort of
curbing the powers of the religious
scholars surveying
greater surveillance of mosques etc and
also suppressing the islamists of all
shades and colors um
but
when he needs the wahhabis
he draws on their help to just give you
an example in the war
on yemen which started in 2015
um
king salman and mohammed bin salman
relied on the wahhabi clerics to go to
the battleground and and encourage the
soldiers to launch this war because they
called it jihad against the infidels and
the infidels in this particular case
were the yemeni zadies who belonged to a
different branch of islam
that the wahhabis hate and detest and
think that they are not real muslims so
that that sort of sectarian discourse
which is uh
integrated in wahhabi doctrine is
promoted in the context of the war on
yemen if for example saudis want to take
any civil resistance if they want to
demonstrate or express an opinion or go
on strike then the the the king and his
son will use the wahhabi fatwas which
are religious decrees to prohibit
demonstrations because they can argue
that it is against islam
and you are committing blasphemy against
god if you demonstrate and therefore at
the moment the wahhabi tradition is
dormant but it can be reactivated on
demand when king salman or his son
mohammed bin salman want to use it it's
out there they can quickly sort of
ignite its zeal and
and excesses
and that's an alliance which has worked
for them for 200 and well more than 250
years
absolutely but at the moment mohammed
bin salman probably thinks that they've
exhausted the islamic legitimacy of the
regime because remember that the saudi
kings are the custodians of the two holy
mosques and therefore they claim that
they are leaders of the sunni muslim
world or of muslims in general but that
had been exhausted and reached a dead
end with the 9 11 event and since then
we see the promotion of nationalism as
an alternative to religious nationalism
so mohammed bin salman adopted the
slogans ironically that trump had
promoted saudi arabia is great or makes
saudi arabia great or saudi arabia is
for saudis
and all these kind of slogans are trying
to create a new national consciousness
to to promote people to push them to to
mobilize them but this nationalism is
centered on loyalty to the to muhammad
bin salman and it's not really a loyalty
to the nation it's loyalty to the future
king and also it has its own
contradictions and problems like all
nationalisms in the world
uh
you just mentioned of course president
trump in his um
you know final hours more or less or
days so most people think anyway in the
white house
uh what is your analysis of the the
changes that have happened in the gulf
in the last few months with the
normalization agreements with the uh
between the emiratis and israel bahrain
as well
sudanese
having their arms somewhat twisted to uh
to join the party
um
where exactly is saudi arabia on that
there was that meeting quite recently
between netanyahu and mbs
and uh you know one of the
the analysis that one reads quite a bit
is simply that
while king salman is still there he
can't
give up the
the arab the saudi authored arab peace
plan which is of course that um
normalization with israel is fine as
long as it follows independence for the
palestinians but once the old man's gone
well who knows
yes well at the moment i think it's the
king's dilemma king salman is damned if
he does damned if he doesn't uh so he
can't he he has to go through a
cost-benefit analysis and see what he's
getting out of of this and in a way you
know trump was his friend and the fra uh
jared kushner was a friend of muhammad
bin salman and they all worked together
but saudi israeli relations date back to
the 1960s and the saudis are actually
the saudi leadership just can't go
public with these relations and they
can't go
along the the path of the united arab
emirates or bahrain or even sudan simply
because they worry about their opinion
of the of the people and they would lose
actually the last sort of brick in their
sort of
legitimacy
narrative they can't
rule without this sort of you know
claim that they uh
work on behalf of muslims given that
they are the custodians of mecca and
medina but king salman
decided to wait and see
and it's interesting that only this week
and
the there was a news that netanyahu came
to saudi arabia for a very quick meeting
with muhammad bin salman and obviously
they denied it although the news came in
the israeli press
but immediately within like a week
prince turki al-faisal who was
ambassador in london and also the
ex-director of the intelligence
services went to a conference in bahrain
double iws
and he sort of had this die tribe about
israel and he was actually talking to
his domestic audience not to the people
in the conference he wanted to reassure
them on behalf of the king and his son
that saudi arabia is committed to the
rights of palestinians but the economic
intelligence and military cooperation
between the two countries saudi arabia
and israel had had developed and there's
a whole sort of um
literature on on the these clandestine
relations
we are nearly running out of time on our
30 minutes before we open this up order
questions but a couple more things so
first off how important in all this is
the shared antipathy that the israelis
and the saudis have to iran
this is the common cause and the
worrying thing is that they are both not
restrained
and they may sort of launch a certain
attack
that would bring the whole region in
into war
um i think mohammed bin salman has uh
overestimated his military capabilities
uh despite i mean
in a country like yemen the war is five
years old in yemen and until now uh
recently the houthi missiles reached
saudi territory and they are intercepted
sometimes they hit a wrong target and we
have seen how the uh the oil fields are
also attacked uh regularly throughout
these five years one attack was so
serious that it stopped the oil
production and export so
in order they are both netanyahu and uh
mohammed bin salman might be foolish to
launch an attack that would bring the
whole region into more war and
devastation
let's talk a little bit about the um
the loving that happened in the early
years of uh mohammed bin salman's tenure
as as crown prince there was that uh
celebrated trip to the united states the
gushing pieces about this great bearer
of a man who might be
who might be king of saudi arabia into
the next century
etc etc etc then of course
things changed greatly after the uh the
murder of hashoji in the consulate in
istanbul uh the celebrated american
columnist tom friedman i think gave him
a very very uh favorable reception when
he burst onto the scene when mbs did um
what do you make of that whole
the whole mechanism the loving then
followed by the
uh the sort of the realization when the
curtain was drawn back
on that terrible killing and what does
that say to you as well about
western observers and
would-be interpreters of what's what's
going on
yes i think thomas friedman and many
others in respectable uh us and uk uh uh
media uh fell under the spell of
mohammed bin salman it was almost like
wishful thinking that he would be this
imposing
young man
very energetic who works until like 3
a.m in the morning and plays video games
i mean there was this sensational
sort of reporting on saudi arabia and
i think um it it goes back earlier than
journalism it goes back to how many uh
travelers and western writers glorified
ibn saud the founder of the kingdom
although he was in alliance with the
most radical religious groups that had
emerged in the arab world for centuries
but i do remember writing reading
british travelers glorifying this man
who came from the desert there is that
kind of
it was the size too they like didn't
they just like with mbs he was a tall
man imposing not like those other little
men i suppose they meant
yes so unfortunately western media fell
under the spell and thought that you
know reform in saudi arabia is all about
allowing women to drive going to theater
watching football matches inviting pop
stars to the country having boxing
matches where women could actually
attend but none of those western
journalists asked the big question the
taboo question is there any sign of
political reform uh is there a sign of
having a representative government in
saudi arabia there were no signs of any
kind of elections and that might take
place and give the people a voice
and only when jamal khashoggi was
murdered on the 2nd of october 2018
that you know thomas friedman and the
others thought that oh we got it wrong
it is time now to reconsider our
assessment this is a brutal murder of
one of us and jamal khashoggi was a
journalist
you mentioned changes to those
restrictions on on women you know the
most celebrated of course the
prohibition on driving and i
have there not been a few reforms the
guardianship system
but do you think that despite the fact
that of course at the same time as he
was allowing some more freedoms he was
putting
female protesters feminists in jail
do you think that uh muhammad bin salman
has made life better in any sense for
women in saudi arabia
some women are enjoying the right to
drive and and this professional women
who have to go to their jobs teachers
nurses doctors etc
but this
comes a very very high price and the
restriction on freedom of expression a
restriction
on women's ability to represent
themselves are still in place until the
present day a saudi woman cannot marry
without the authorization or the
permission of her guardian so in
marriage women are not regarded as
adults and they need to be represented
and they have to seek permission to get
married so yes there are certain changes
that had affected women in a positive
way but i think you can't talk about
this kind of social liberalization
without real rights without real
political right without the idea of
equal citizenship and we are still far
behind
other countries in the region let alone
in in the world and so yes there is
reform but there is heavy-handed
repression at the same time legend
who is a feminist young
30 year old
activist who campaigned for the right to
drive and got arrested and put in prison
in 2014
but she's still in prison now
and when mohammed bin salman came to
power
she was summoned to prison and
she is now transferred to a court that
deals with terrorism and she is just
an educated woman who
campaign but it is not surprising that
mohammed bin salman picked those women
and put them in prison because the
feminist movement in saudi arabia had
surpassed
all schisms within society whether they
are regional ideological
or even
sectarian so women's right you united so
many regions so many tribal groups and
this is why mohammed bin salman feared
this
rising
vocal feminist movement and he prefers
regions and groups to work within their
own sect within their own community but
a national opposition is what he
actually fears
right we have got um variety of
questions coming in as a matter of fact
so let's uh start dealing with a couple
of those um
can you this is from ananda
could you talk a little bit about mbs
and his relationship with the united
arab emirates who is the senior partner
and how will the election of joe biden
change this
yeah and it is a very very um opaque
relationship but i think mohammed bin
salman's season this is this is the
relationship with mbz the yes and the
ruler the effective ruler of that of
that country um
he is impressed by dubai rather than the
whole of the uae and he thought that he
could turn saudi arabia into another uae
on a much bigger scale
and
his relation obviously like all these
kind of
personalized political relations it's
very difficult to know what goes on but
it is obvious that uh the uae
early on wanted to play a role bigger
than its size and even its wealth
and
they saw the threat of uh islamism in
the region
as undermining their success story or
the so-called success story of dubai
and i think the decision was reached in
the u in abu dhabi the capital that in
order to defeat islamism you really need
to defeat it in its own country of
origin and that is saudi arabia so mbz
is very keen on silencing all islamist
voices and becoming the policeman of the
gulf
um and he he has uh uh played sort of
the guiding uh uh
elder to mohammed bin salman uh so far
but we shall see like all these kind of
personalized relations they are not
based on some kind of solid
institutional connections and they come
and go
depending on personalities in in power
um and uh and i'll ask say a follow-up
did the
uae player a role in the appointment of
mbs there was apparently an article in
the new york times which i clearly
missed suggesting there was a very
strong link on that
uh it
i mean mbz uh through his ambassador in
washington
he built uh uh many connections and he
reminds me of
his ambassador reminds me of bender bun
sultan if you remember jeremy in the
1990s and then before
and even up to 9 11. so he had these
personalized
relations with the bush family with the
oil
corporations
and
i think after the departure of muhammad
of bender bin sultan the saudi
ambassador and the uae wanted to fill
that vacuum and play the role and sort
of be the the sounding board of the
american administration and it coincided
with trump uh coming to power who was
very much interested in the
transactional foreign policy that you
know if you buy my arms or arms from my
country i'm happy to support you and and
that went on and mohammed bin salman
benefited from that kind of context um
on the subject of arms is a question
from me actually um
do you think the uh well we hear a lot
in this country but the british and the
americans clearly we sell vast amounts
of uh
weaponry sophisticated weaponry to saudi
arabia and there is that intelligence
relationship and if you talk to
um
members of the conservative government
here for example about our relations
with saudi arabia they'll say well yes
that we have put pressure on them on
some issues because we're not that happy
with some of the things they've been
doing like bombing civilians in yemen
with planes we sold them and maintained
um
but you know the relationship is very
important economically and as well as
that it's deeply rooted in our common
history we go back a long way
and uh and as well as that of course
there's that intelligence relationship
and believe you me is what they say the
saudis have helped us no end in dealing
with extremism in our own country
well i mean this is the uh the discourse
of successive british governments um and
also in the united states uh but it i
think the in terms of cost benefit and
there had been a lot of studies on
british relations with saudi arabia and
the arms sales
and it is
actually blown out of proportion yes
there are jobs but they're not the only
jobs in the country and britain could
have a a foreign policy
with a country like saudi arabia and
upholding its values and it doesn't mean
that you sell them these planes that are
used to bomb yemen you you make that
relationship conditional on these uh
regimes and these dictatorships
respecting the basic rights of their
citizens and their neighbors but um i
think britain likes the idea
of having this so yet another special
relationship with saudi arabia because
it makes it project its power abroad it
makes it feel better that they have this
really special inverted commas with the
saudis but i mean since the second world
war this had been the dilemma of britain
as the united states displaced britain
in terms of having the special
relationship with with saudi arabia and
and the british logic is that if we
don't sell sell saudi arabia arms then
the french would and this is the kind of
uh
weapons market that is global uh backed
by powerful governments and and they're
all searching for new opportunities and
markets unfortunately and you know
without a vigorous um control over arms
sales and we we are going to continue
pumping these regimes with weapons that
are used either against their own people
or against their neighbors and you
accelerate the chances of a war as we
have seen the yemen war was the first
war that the saudis
used to to test their military
capabilities they've never fought a war
on on their own their
has never fought a war on its own since
the creation of the state the gulf war
in 1990
was fought with 500 000 foreign soldiers
mainly americans and therefore and they
wanted to test their military
capabilities and and and started a war
in yemen that that precipitated the
humanitarian crisis that is still
ongoing
uh let's talk a little bit about the the
the murder of jamal hashoji
um
some men have been put on trial
uh what is likely to happen to them um
mbs himself has denied that he had
anything to do with it though i think
trump isn't trump said to woodward that
uh i saved that guy's ass
on this particular subject
um
so
if they took the orders
of the crown prince if of course i can't
prove it but all the circumstantial
evidence seems to suggest that the
question is will they take the fall for
him uh will how does it work will their
families have been
given money to buy their silence will
they be discreetly ushered out of jail
in a year or two
yes well it's an opaque
judiciary in saudi arabia and we
don't know much about
the process the procedure
and they needed to have scapegoats to
silence their loud voices around the
world uh that condemned this this uh
crime
and
the the magnitude of the crime makes one
believe uh with certainty that it could
not have happened without some serious
orders from above
and and the details of it at the time
were horrific and i documented in the
book because i relied on on the accounts
of the woman who was with khashoggi just
standing outside his fiancee
and the saudis would not allow an
independent
uh
investigation they refused from day one
and they regarded that as an
infringement on their sovereignty but
sovereignty or no sovereignty you commit
a crime abroad on the premises of your
consulate i think the regime has gone
too far in that particular well
that does appear yeah that very much
does appear to be the consensus though
of course um western countries certainly
seem quite prepared to
forgive and forget as soon as they they
can um an interesting question here from
the audience uh do you think that saudi
arabia could ever be a democracy what
would need to happen
well it can be a democracy there's
nothing that stops a country from being
a democracy
you need
two
conditions you need the people to
mobilize for democracy
inside the country
and you need an international context
that doesn't block the development of
democracy like what happened in in egypt
for example in 2011 when people did
demonstrate and did uh pay a high price
but then there were
counter-revolutionary forces in the
region assisted by some western
governments that derailed that drive
towards democracy and saudi arabia is
not an exceptional case there are people
calling for democracy we do have now a
diaspora that consists of
young men and women who had left
the reforms and the the paradise of
mohammed bin salman and they're stranded
in around the globe from canada to the
united states britain australia europe
and any and other countries and one
thing that actually encouraged me to
write this book is to
ask a question if mohammed bin salman is
such a great reformer why are those
saudis leaving the country and becoming
exiles and asylum seekers abroad
women
if he's promoting and empowering women
why have we got runaway girls and this
is a new phenomena runaway girls young
girls who leave the country without the
permission of their guardians
they escape and once they arrive in
international airports around the world
they seek asylum so if if driving is the
dream of every saudi woman why do these
young women leave the country when
driving becomes uh legal
so it's it's a very very mixed uh um
situation um and democracy is not uh
beyond the the horizon of many saudis
they can participate in nor in elections
they understand the principles of
democracy
um now
your family and you yourself of course
have been outside saudi arabia
quite a long time long you know much
perceiving
um mohammed bin salman tell us what your
family's story was
it's a long story but uh we've got about
we've got about five minutes are gone
right
uh well i mean it it's you're i'm born
into a family that had a history in in
the country as local rulers of part of
what is now saudi arabia and they had
battles uh and they lost uh the war to
the uh to the al saud
but also they they uh are interconnected
through a series of marriages uh with
the al saud because they're part of this
arabian sort of nobility
and and in my situation i sort of became
an exile as a teenager i didn't choose
to be an exile it's because of the
position of my father my uncle and and
the whole family
history so i left in saudi arabia 75
then returned briefly and then at the
end i came to britain to study and
decided to stay and
i i
i chose a career that can never flourish
in a dictatorship you cannot write
history or social science in a country
like saudi arabia if you if you want to
maintain your
ability to have critical thinking and it
is impossible
all my books are banned in saudi arabia
in fact amnesty international reported
that one of the charges against a group
of civil society activists and when they
went to court in
saudi arabia that they had my books and
articles stored on their computer so if
a history book or
definitely the sun king will not be
allowed in saudi arabia it will be
censored but if you can't write
with freedom if you can't defend human
rights if you can't
engage in conversation with feminists
islamists nationalists and if you can't
do all these things you can't really
become an academic in saudi arabia
unless you become a loyalist academic
and i chose not not to go down that path
because i i couldn't be
a loyalist in a regime that deprives me
of my basic freedom of speech now this
excellent book and i um here we are show
you the cover again um is full
of really
very forensic criticisms
of the sun king the title itself
uh of uh mohammed bin salman do you ever
feel in danger yourself you've been
every bit as critical as uh hashoji was
yes i mean i've been in danger a long
time ago when i published my phd
thesis in 1991
and i i received threats that if if i
was going to publish it i will be
subjected to disciplinary action
and that came from the saudi government
before mbs
but after khashoggi was murdered
all saudi exiles and there was a growing
community in london and in washington
everywhere and we became very very um
um troubled by how far the regime could
go to eliminate uh
critical voices
but
if if i'm gonna live in fear i should go
back to saudi arabia i cannot live
abroad in fear because of my writing or
what my writing would call
and once you make that decision then
you know
you dismiss this moment of
fear
and
i i do believe that i'm only writing
words um and obviously words are not
appreciated in dictatorships so um
i will continue my academic career my
writing and
i i
deliberately take the side of the people
the who are in saudi prisons and of the
women who are detained simply for asking
for certain rights that the whole popul
the whole world enjoys
and once you make that decision i think
you you
become um
a target
um and you won't be accepting any
invitations to
conferences in saudi arabia with
a private jet to take you there
well absolutely not i wouldn't even
go to the saudi embassy in london or the
consulate i do remember as a student in
britain my saudi passport expired and i
would not go
to the embassy or the consulate to renew
my passport because i knew and i had the
awareness that governments can do nasty
things in in their consulates or
embassies because their sovereign
territories belonging to them we are
just well well quite right yeah well
there's proof isn't there so um we are
almost running out of time but time for
a couple of quick questions
oil
as we try to use less oil
in the rest of the world what effect is
that going to have on saudi arabia whose
economy is of course already getting
squeezed
yes absolutely there is a shift and it
is uh in world consumption even without
covert uh and for a country that is
totally dependent on oil
mohammed bin salman is trying to
diversify but it doesn't happen
overnight they had been used to uh oil
revenues and uh part of his plan
in vision 2030 is to
to increase the diversification of the
economy and we shall see uh it's he he
has been forced to draw on um the
national sovereign fund uh to cover uh
ex government expenditure and also
borrowing so that is going to
actually change the dynamics the
political dynamics be
between
the ruling family and society
a society that has been used to a
welfare state that is well developed
housing education
scholarships abroad and all that is
going to stop
um
we've got a few more questions i just
wanted to get on to there was one that
was asked some time ago actually
you know there have been so there's been
some talk that the custody of the uh the
holy mosque in jerusalem might be
transferred to saudi arabia at the
moment formally it's of course in the
hands of jordan do you see anything in
that any bit
i doubt it actually um
[Music]
very difficult to do yeah yeah
okay um
let's talk a little bit about uh
the
jihadist extremists al-qaeda
some extent isis the question is
uh the saudi elite funded and supported
al-qaeda and to some extent isis what
would it take for us to see that dynamic
re-emerging
as i said earlier um you know the
wahhabi tradition is still there
and it is used at the moment selectively
in the war um on yemen
and uh in sort of
suppressing any kind of political
activism in the country
and as long as it's there
you know it can be reactivated
um if we look just briefly at the
history the heavy movement emerged in
the 18th century and then the ottoman
empire destroyed it at the beginning of
the 19th century but it was still there
and it was revived by the el saud at the
beginning of the 20th century with the
help of the british government at the
time
so it it goes in cycles and i wouldn't
be surprised if
it splinters into something else and
erupts in different ways but you have to
think of it as a totalitarian system and
any totalitarian system is subject to
being fractured and you have splinter
group emerging because they argue about
the interpretation of their doctrines
and texts all the time and
the the jihadi tradition or the al-qaeda
they used aspect of the wahhabi
tradition interpreted in a different way
so they and the loyal wahabis only
differ slightly about interpretation of
their doctrine because they have the
same source and and this we know like
totalitarian system always break up and
always have radical fringe movements and
and
i wouldn't be surprised if it erupts
again in in some time in the future
uh tell us how significant saudi support
was for
al-qaeda during its more prominent days
and of course
various affiliates very much still exist
and when i put these questions myself to
you know
important or unimportant people in saudi
arabia they say well look we worked very
hard to to to stop these people we
eliminated them it's absolutely wrong to
say that uh
the saudis um
expedited those particular
movements in different parts not just to
the middle east but elsewhere where does
the truth lie on that one
well it said there are historical
records that
many historians academics including
myself had consulted and
the the whole idea of this uh global
jihad you go to afghanistan first and
they thought that they could it is the
child of
many governments and not only the saudi
government so
saudi arabia provided the doctrine and
the money
the united states britain and other
countries pushed for that uh
project and pakistan facilitated it on
the ground so
in order to defeat the soviet union they
thought radical islam or islam at the
time could be an antidote to communism
and it can mobilize muslims around the
globe
to go to afghanistan and liberate it and
and that was the the the the saudi
government's
active participation
you i don't know many how many people
know that king salman himself was
running a fund to help the jihadis to go
to afghanistan and also they were given
a reduction on saudi airline to fly to
peshawar and to other cities in pakistan
and regroup with osama bin laden so that
that phase is forgotten
as saudi arabia switched from a
supporter of that
afghan jihad to being a victim of of
that jihad um
so it was easier for them to fall out
with the saudi leadership and turn
against the saudi leadership and the
saudi leadership
also
started feeling the pressure in between
20
2003 and 2008 saudi arabia witnessed the
worst uh terrorism episode in its modern
history because those afghan arabs as
they were called
returned to saudi arabia and started a
terrorism campaign so they actually
tasted what they have been exporting
and it's it's it was a misguided policy
on behalf of several governments to
weaponize islam in the fight against the
soviet union that weaponization we are
still living under the
dark side of that misguided foreign
policy
um
madawi we are
we've finally run out of time i'd like
to thank you very much for taking part
in what for me has been and i'm sure for
everybody else an absolutely fascinating
hour i'd like to thank of course not
just you but the audience intelligence
squared i'd also like to remind
everybody watching here that you can get
well not just one copy you can order
multiple copies of the book with the
intelligent square discount and that is
via the link in the chat tab at the
right hand side of uh
of your screen and uh
you know it's been really really
interesting and by the way um
guys there are lots of books around at
the moment about this particular man
forget this one start here the others
are good too but this is the one that
matters this is where you begin so thank
you so much once again for uh talking to
us this evening
thank you
yes thank you jeremy and madawi and just
to reiterate what uh was already said by
jeremy thank you all for your amazing
questions i can already see in the chat
top we have sean and kathy thanking uh
madawi and jeremy for their
contributions it was really fascinating
taking us right through from the history
of saudi arabia to
the future of the kingdom quick reminder
if you did enjoy the event the sun came
one more show of the book
yeah
do get the intelligent square discount
via the via the chat tab and reminder if
you did see jeremy's dog walk in and
you'd like to hear more about cats vs
dogs that's tomorrow's debate on
intelligence squared so do tune in for
that and and plenty more coming up on
intelligence squared in the coming weeks
thanks again to madawi and jeremy and
have a lovely evening